i don't really define
success it's not sort of a word that
preoccupies me
when you define success you might be
completely undershooting
your potential right that's the danger
when you when you think of the world in
that way whereas we're always looking at
you know how deep can we reach how high
can we aim
given what we what we have to work with
here so that's that's really
our our mindset towards everything i am
frank slootman i am the chairman and ceo
of snowflake
we're a newer generation of software
companies
we are enabling massively scaled
very very high performance analytical
data processes
this day and age business processes
are end-to-end digital and data becomes
the
beating heart of their of their
enterprises and
snowflake is what enables that
things are going to change dramatically
in the world of data i mean historically
you know data has been used for
reporting it's been used for populating
dashboards
where we're moving now is that where
data is literally driving
digital operations and with the
requirements that come
with that in terms of what the platforms
have to be capable of
things like machine learning and ai it's
very different
i think uh there's a bit of a
misunderstanding around ipos that it's
some
kind of biblical uh event that sort of
changes the world
and from where i'm sitting having done
this you know a number of times
it's a blip on the radar it comes in it
goes it's a mile marker
during a marathon it's not nearly as
consequential as people think and
we're we're not mesmerized by it we're
not obsessed with it
it comes and it goes and by the way the
process of taking companies public is
is not that hard if you have a good
company by the way
it's actually it's uh you know another
in the case of snowflake it was
incredibly easy because the demand
you know outstripped the supply by by
orders uh
of magnitude
when i was a kid you know i there were a
few years where
i wasn't having very good grades and i
remember my dad telling me uh
you know i don't really care what your
grades are as long as you're putting
everything into it
that you have and then you know we will
accept whatever that is
what that means is it's very much i'm
very much focused on the inputs not on
the outcomes
my worry is that you know when i join a
company like snowflake i'm being
handed a promise a potential right
and my role in the company is to
deliver around that potential to the
absolute fullest and you know we live in
in perpetual you know fear and anxiety
that we are not fully delivering uh on
the potential that we are
are handed i have empathy with a lot of
quarterbacks that don't know how to
retire
because you know you know what it feels
like to be
you know in in those in those very very
tense
you know highly charged situations and
being able to prevail
and you can never reproduce that when
you leave the field you just can't
you'll never be better than when you're
under the gun and when the demands are
are very very great and the problems are
difficult
and complex right i mean one of the
things you notice when you're
uh in so-called retirement you start to
atrophy
you know pretty quickly i mean not not
in a very obvious
uh way but you know you're just feeling
the uh
the edge uh you know starts to become
dull
people like me don't like that uh you
know we we
are uh feeling our best when we're being
our best and the only way to be your
best is to subject
yourself to the most demanding uh set of
circumstances
being in the arena is sort of a natural
habitat
you know for me it makes me feel like
you know i am going to be the sharpest
all i'll ever
i'll ever be
you